الايرانية تقترب من سفن حربية
بمضيق هرمز في تحركات عسكرية
فلما كل هذا الخوف يا هؤلاء اعلن
الجيش الامريكي ان البحرية
الامريكي بريك ماجورك يزور
الجزائر بعد نحو اسبوع من اعلان
العسكرية في سوريا. مصادر تركية
تقول ان الجانب الامريكي اقترح
المنشآت النفطية قبل النظر في
المقترح الامريكي. بينما اضافت
اعادة هيكلة قوات سوريا
الديموقراطية ومنح دور اكبر
القلق الامريكي من اندفاع
الجزائر نحو موسكو لم ينتهي بعد.
مقابل تقديم تنازلات ميدانية
وسياسية في سوريا. الاحداث
تطورات. منسق الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا في مجلس الامن القومي
الاوكراني. من جانب اخر وبعد وضع
تركيا لشروطها لايقاف العملية
عليه بقضايا الطاقة. بينما علقت
واشنطن على زيارة الرئيس الصيني
جديد. بخطوات ثابتة تصعد الصين
نحو القمة لكنها لا تمشي وحدها.
المتحدة برد نووي في حال وقوع
هجوم يستهدف اراضيها. فهل تقرع
الصواريخ والقذائف. فهنا جيش
كوريا الشمالية يصدر امرا طارئا
السوري ويقدم نفسه كمنقذ للبشرية
كما فعل في صفقة الحبوب
الاتراك عن التوسع في شتى
المجالات. هنا صحيفة لوموند
المصادر ذاتها ان روسيا وضعت
شروطا تتعلق بالملف الاوكراني
ضمن خيارات بيونج يانج. وكل من
يعترض طريقها سيأخذ نصيبه من
الفتاكة نحن مصدرها. نحن فخورون
رغم اننا لم ننجح بعد في ذلك.
نحو روسيا. لترد الاخيرة على
الامر ساخرة على لسان ديمتري
ذاتها اشترطت تركيا انهاء سيطرة
قوات سوريا الديموقراطية على
الفرنسية تتحدث عن اردوغان انه
يلجأ لخطة الحرب للتغلب على
تراجع شعبيته قبل الانتخابات
ليهدد باشعال الحرب في الشمال
بكين لن تلجأ النووية تحت اي ظرف
متهمة واشنطن بمحاولة تشويه
الصين طمنت الولايات المتحدة حيث
اكدت وزارة الدفاع الصينية ان
تغضب الغرب. من الحرب الى السلم.
ومن السلاح الى الغذاء لا يتوقف
السياسة الدفاعية الصينية وكذلك
تأجيج التوترات العالمية. تركيا
من خلال اطفاء سفنها لاجهزة
التعقب لتسير مظلمة في جنوب
العقوبات الغربية بطريقة خبيثة.
هنا تقرير لصحيفة الجارديان
وبين هذا وذاك دعا رئيس الحكومة
اللينغاري فيكتور اولبان الى
تتلائم مع النظام الدولي. فما
الذي يتلائم اذا ايها الامريكان?
الى السعودية ان المملكة لا تزال
حليفا مهما للولايات المتحدة.
وزير الطاقة السعودي. المملكة
ستظل شريكا للصين يمكن الوثوق به
لكنها حذرت من ان محاولات الصين
توسيع نطاق نفوذها حول العالم لا
الحرب طبولها في شبه الجزيرة
الكورية? فلندعو الله ان يتزوج
جميع مشتركي قناة شهد لتعرف. قبل
ان تندلع اي حرب نووي تحالف صيني
بيونج يانج ان وضعها كقوة نووية
امر لا رجوع فيه متوعدة الولايات
البولاندية والذي رفضته في
السابق فهل ترد روسيا على ذلك
الى حليفه الروسي في الحرب
الاوكرانية ومن الجارة الحليفة
الروسي بارسال قطع غيار دبابات
تي سفنتي تو السوفيتية الى الجيش
موسكو. لتظهر هنا تأهات الخوف
والتناقض الامريكي. حيث قالت
مشبوهة ومقلقة لواشنطن. كل حرب
مصيرها ان تنتهي بالتفاوض وهو ما
دولية في الرياض. فما الذي يخبئه
شي هذه المرة يا ترى ليعلنها
لجميع وحداته القتالية بالتأهب
على جميع المستويات. كما اعلنت
انقلاب في برلين للاطاحة
بالحكومة. وبدأت على اثرها
العقوبات الى خدع الانقلابات.
حيث كادت سلطات المانيا ان تفقد
الغاء مناورات مع روسيا على
الحدود المغربية وهذا يوضح ان
حيث وصل الرئيس الصيني شي جين
بينغ السعودية ليحضر ثلاث قمم
العربي في ادارة منبج وتل رفعة
عين العرب هناك. وبحسب المصادر
السلطات حملة امنية كبيرة وبكل
خفة ورشاقة تتوجه اصابع الاتهام
الزعيم الكوري يعلن حالة
الطوارئ. العودة الى الوراء ليست
ميدفيديف الذي قال امر بديهي ان
يتهموننا بذلك. لان جميع
المؤامرات الخبيثة والحروب
العالمية المدمرة والاوبئة
المضادة لسقف اسعار النفط. وعلى
الغرب الاستعداد لكل شيء. نحذر
المتحدث باسم الكريملين روسيا
تتفق مع امريكا بشأن الحاجة الى
عالميا. وان خطر الحرب النووية
يتصاعد حسب قوله ليضيف ان موسكو
في وجه العدو برغم ان اسلحتها
النووية هي الاحدث والاقوى
كراسيها في الحكم لتكشف وسائل
اعلام الماني عن افشال محاولة
بروسيا لتجنب الابلاغ عن صادرات
النفط الخاصة بها. ومن مكر
المحيط الاطلسي وتنقل السفن سرا
النفط الى حاويات لا علاقة لها
مراجعة العقوبات المفروضة على
روسيا مشيرا الى ان ثمن حرب
الاوكراني. لكن لم تأتي هذه
العملية دون مقابل اذ اقترحت
بدعم المغرب غير المسبوق
لاوكرانيا في حربها ضد الهجوم
الى الجارة المعادية ونقصد
بولندا التي اعلنت قبولها العرض
الاستعداد على اعلى مستوى. فهل
حان وقت انضمام الجيش البلاروسي
البريطانية تحدث عن خطة ماكرة
تتبعها روسيا العقوبات الغربية
اوكرانيا ليس هو نفسه على جانبي
الاطلسي. لكن روسيا تتحيل على
الغيار تلك. وكما يقولها
المصريون دبور وزن على خرب عشه.
تطوير صواريخ بعيدة المدى
بقدراتها الذاتية. لنبسطها اكثر
اعلنت وزارة الدفاع البلاروسية
ان القوات المسلحة بدأت تدريبات
الامريكي قال في الوقت نفسه ان
واشنطن لا تمنع اوكرانيا من
اقرار سلام دائم في اوكرانيا.
وها هو بوتين يحسم موعد نهاية
لبلاده. داريا بكوف ويحذر امريكا
والناتو. ان نكشف عن اجراءاتنا
الاراضي الروسية او خارج حدودها.
لكن لويد استن وزير الدفاع
المستويات. والرئيس الصيني يجد
نفسه في الاحضان فيما اردوغان
بسبب الهجمات الاوكرانية لترد
موسكو برشقات غزيرة وبصواريخ
يستخدم نظرية الحرباء ويقترب من
تحقيق اهدافه. الثأر الروسي.
اي بل تقصف روسيا ولكن لا تستخدم
الاسلحة الامريكية. افهمتم فيما
لمناقشة الضمانات الامنية اذا
كان الغرب مستعدا لذلك. لكنه
رياكوف نائب وزير الخارجية
الروسي ان بلاده مستعدة للعودة
واشنطن انها لا تشجع اوكرانيا
ولا تمكنها من شن هجمات صوب
ستدافع عن حلفائها بكافة الوسائل
ان الضرورة ذلك. ليعلنها سيرجي
روسيا لا تلوح بالسلاح النووي
ولا تتلاعب به كاداة حادة بيدها
الولايات المتحدة تسليم المغرب
دبابات ام ون ابرمز عوضا عن قطع
لتكشف عن عملية ابقتها امريكا
قيد الكتمان لدعم كييف. وذلك
الذي طرحته المانيا بنصب بطاريات
صواريخ باتريوت على الاراضي
لتغيير قواعد المعارك فبعد ان
تعرضت قاعدتان جويتان روسيتان
اضاف ان موسكو قد تنظر الى رفع
الحظر الاختياري على نشر صواريخ
الولايات المتحدة والناتو من
اتخاذ خطوات متهورة لاختبار صبر
متوسطة بعيدة المدى اذا واصل
الغرب التصعيد. بينما قال
الروسي القضايا المتعلقة بتوفير
الامن الداخلي في روسيا ويؤكد ان
لننتقل الى الطرف الاخر بوتين
والذي يبحث مع اعضاء مجلس الامن
ودولة عربية تقف في وجه روسيا
بعد ان كشف امرها فما الذي يجري
العرض الالماني. فهل تتدخل موسكو
في ذلك? وبينما يراوغ بوتين
وقتا اطول ولكن انضمت لروسيا
اراض جديدة وهي نتيجة مهمة
الزللسكي في خط المواجهة بدون بس
واصفا دومبس بانها صعبة جدا.
وزيننسكي يظهر في دومبس لاول
مرة. المانيا تعلن افشال مخطط
بوتين يعلنها في وجه امريكا لا
تظن اننا سنترك حلفائنا دون
عالية الدقة مستهدفة مواقع
عسكرية اوكرانية والبنى التحتية
حماية. فلتستعد للقادم. وبعد ان
وصلت صواريخ اوكرانيا الى روسيا.
القاذفات الروسية في قاعدة
انجليز العسكرية وقد لحق بها ضرر
العقوبات الغربية بلا روسيا تعلن
استعدادها دخول الحرب الروسية
وجيش مجنون كوريا يعلن حالة
الطوارئ ويتأهب على جميع
يقوله الروس والاوكران لكن كل
بطريقته الخاصة. فهل اقترب موعد
الحرب. مصرحا ان ظهور نتائج
العملية العسكرية يمكن ان يستغرق
للطاقة. لنختصر الاحداث. لقد
حدثت محرقة صاروخية. ليظهر بعدها
للاطاحة بنظامها الجمهوري. وتوجه
اصابع صوب موسكو وبولندا تقبل
للقصف بمسيرات اوكرانية صور
لاقمار صناعية اظهرت ضخما من
الحرب تدخل منعرجا اخر وكل يشحذ
سيفه. نعم فهناك اهداف جديدة
راك عارفين
واشنطن تتبرأ من كييف وقواعد
الحرب تتغير في اوكرانيا
سلام.